drôle
allez-vous juste coucher avec
n'importe qui excusez-moi allez-vous juste
coucher avec beaucoup d'autres femmes est-ce
quelque chose que vous faites beaucoup de
question privée n'est-ce pas euh alors est en
moi assez enceinte donc la connexion
là je  Je demande combien de fois vous faites
combien de fois diriez-vous que vous prenez des
femmes que vous ne connaissez pas très bien et que vous
avez des relations sexuelles avec elles et que vous êtes à l'intérieur d'elles
ouais ouais vous connaissez leurs noms ouais ouais
toujours toujours ouais ouais alors quel est mon
nom je  connais ton nom d'accord alors bon
qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est stupide
quelqu'un qui connaîtrait le nom de quelqu'un
dirait juste bien sûr je connais ton
nom je sais que tu sais ce que c'est
des ramassages fatigants sur le timing qu'ils plafonnaient
tout le temps ouais d'accord ouais
eh bien mes premières questions générales
quels sont les plus grands défis dans la
gestion d'un musée bienvenue dans la jungle
bientôt vous serez confronté à un
animal sauvage car vous connaissez tous l'
instinct de chasse  est le déclencheur  ered par la faiblesse si vous
montrez de la peur, l'animal vous traquera
mais si vous restez parfaitement immobile, l'
animal pourrait ne pas vous remarquer et vous pouvez vous
cacher dans le troupeau en sachant
que quelqu'un d'autre sera le
fournisseur de proies
Joris
bien c'est l'hôtesse pour  musclé pour
quelque chose
[Musique]
alors comment la peur peut être opium mais
authentique comique
si une grosse dinde
tu vas juste avoir des relations sexuelles avec beaucoup d'autres
femmes genre de question privée dont
tu t'appelles